Southwest Gas is Raising its rates and
you're probably less than thrilled if
this affects you customers packed last
night's Public Utilities Commission
meeting Nevada law requires utilities to
file annual rate adjustment applications
and give reasons for those increases
dozens of customers gathered last night
to say they're struggling already with
inflation and as utility bills go up
again many say they can't keep up
we close all the events we sleep under
pounds of covers we wear you know roads
when we get out of bed to try and keep
our gas bill down but still it's so high
if approved the average Southern Nevada
single family monthly bill would see an
increase of about 2.77 that's a 4.8
percent increase so